les gestes mille fois répétés les
habitués de frais de ce prime lui
confient leur tête et bien souvent leurs
pensées le sujet de l'heure selon le
barbier c'est le vaccin contre la
coqueluche cette perspective encore
lointaine pour bien des gens n'en
veulent pas ce jeune homme
personnellement je vais attendre avant
de le faire d'utile pour voir ce que ça
donnera
quand les américains auront été
massivement vacciner l'une de ses
connaissances
et pourtant morte de l'aco vide mais il
trouve que le vaccin est trop nouveau ce
prix lui contre le recevoir
certains que ses clients seront prêts à
limiter le choc mais c'est sur ce lien
de confiance que mise un réseau de
recherche et de prévention en santé pour
rejoindre les afro-américains dans les
endroits qu'ils fréquentent et où il se
sent bien
staios les barbiers les salons de
coiffure noir joue un rôle de premier
plan dans la vie de leur communauté
depuis l'époque de l'esclavagé soutient
ce professeur qui se trame un cadre
informel plus propice aux potins et aux
confidences
mais il assure que le réseau diffuse de
l'information scientifique nature
la peur du vaccin est plus forte que
celle de la maladie chez bien des
afro-américains qui meurent pourtant
deux fois plus de l'aco vide que la
population blanche ben rhodes un
scepticisme ancrée dans l'histoire car
la recherche médicale aux états unis a
été ponctuée d'expérience raciste
le souvenir le plus vif et celui du
scandale de tous qui guy une étude
clinique de la syphilis effectués sur
600 hommes noirs pauvres en alabama les
cobayes recruté en 1932 n'ont jamais su
qu'ils en étaient atteints ni eu droit à
la pénicilline qui aurait pu les guérir
l'expérience a duré quarante ans il y a
eu des dédommagements et des excuses
[Applaudissements]
sont
surmonter les réticences est cruciale on
accepte tout type de vaccin pour tenter
d'y arriver
un symbole la première dose aux états
unis administré par sept médecins à
cette infirmière qui veut rassurer
public de l'émerveillement de voir deux
des leurs à la une et l'espoir qu'on
entende enfin leur communauté pour
s'attaquer aux problèmes comme le manque
d'accès aux soins et la prévalence de
maladies comme le diabète chez les afro
américains mais en provenance des
inégalités révélée au grand jour par la
crise sanitaire et qui les ont rendues
encore plus vulnérables à la coved 19 et
il faudrait aller régler autrement sauf
si cynique béraud radio-canada
kensington au maryland